Haben wir bisher vielleicht mit den falschen methoden nach aliens gesucht finden wir mit unseren
radioteleskopen vielleicht gar keine signale und müssen wir noch etwas ganz anderem suchen das meinen jedenfalls die beiden serbischen forscher milan cirkovic
Und branislav micic sie glauben dass er ins riesige
schutzschilden ihre heimatplaneten gebaut haben müssten die wir nur zu suchen brauchen wieso weshalb warum
Jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Unsere ehe wurde bereits viele male von kosmischen katastrophen heimgesucht asteroiden einschläge sind sicher
sternenexplosionen in der nähe
wahrscheinlich und gablitz sicher ist
Mehrmals gab es ein massensterben hier auf der erde und die ursachen dürften oft aus dem weltraum gekommen sein weiter entwickelte
außerirdische zivilisationen könnten dann gegen schutzschilde gebaut haben damit drohende katastrophen nicht ihre zivilisation
Zerstören schon in den 60er jahren gab es ja die idee
Dass zivilisation riesige strukturen um ihren heimatstern herum gebaut haben könnten um energie zu gewinnen
Die sogenannten weißen sphären bisher wurden allerdings keine solchen sphären gefunden obwohl beim stern hd 16 45 95
Gibt es sehr seltsame schwankungen der helligkeit
teppichs stern manche wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerin
Schließen eine dyson sphäre dort nicht aus und auch die neueste these eines planeten mittring system
das durch den stern quasi durchgeknetet wird ist als grund für die unregelmäßigen helligkeitsschwankungen sehr umstritten so oder so aber
glauben die beiden wissenschaftler dass außerirdische
intelligente wesen solche riesigen struktur auf jeden fall zum schutz bauen würden auch die menschheit vermuten sie
wird bald damit anfangen zum beispiel könnten sie eine riesige schützende struktur
Aus eisbrocken aus dem kupfergürtel bauen die
Im falle eines falles die erde schützen würde eine solche wolke
Wäre so die forscher gar nicht, so aufwendig zu bauen dementsprechend
gehen sie davon aus dass intelligente aliens längst solche risiken strukturen gebaut haben und
wir nur nach danach suchen müssten ihre idee zur verbesserten alien suche wir müssen nur
Nach sich anbahnenden kosmischen katastrophen suchen und nach exoplaneten in der nähe hier
so müssten der gravitationswellen
Im vorfeld der ereignisse selektieren und dann die umgebung absuchen hier müssen wir jetzt zum beispiel nach helligkeit mustern suchen die solche riesigen
strukturen verursachen würden zudem sollten wir nach infrarotstrahlung suchen die durch solche strukturen ausgesendet werden
es gibt mit diesem ansatz vielleicht schnellere ergebnisse
als wir bisher bei der ebenso raten beziehungsweise wir hatten ja keine und mit dem james webb, weltraumteleskop
Das im nächsten jahr gestartet wird und alle bisherigen
weltraumteleskope bei weitem in den schatten stellen wird werden wir auch deutlich bessere chancen bei der alien genre haben hierbei geht es um
Halte ich euch natürlich dazu auf dem laufenden wenn er kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen auf verpassen wollt dann und mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich dem
Auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit finden wir noch dieses jahr außerirdische eine
verlockende perspektive auf jeden fall also nicht verpassen und draufklicken ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran